refutes himself
at the beginning. He'll
say
this
perfect
natural
book.
Why
author
who is
change?
Even if he
and so
We look at
it
teenager
opposed to
very very early in his scholar career,
his career as a scholar that he passed
away. Yet in spite of that he was able
to compile and write very groundbreaking
books. So never take a book that was
written by a man under the assumption
that it is perfect and if you see some
imperfection it's not good enough. This
is ridiculous and fantastical and there
is no human being who is perfect in that
way. As a matter of fact, the
scholars of hadith when they used to go
to the
gatherings of their teachers, they
had a tradition where some of them would
give charity on their way to the
gathering.
And they would give charity in order to
make the dua, "Oh Allah, hide our
teachers imperfections from us, his
mistakes."
Why? Because a shan uses the
imperfections of a scholar in order to
plant seeds in the minds of his students
in the minds of his followers to try to
turn people away from the path of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Make us blind
to make us help us to overlook his his
shortcomings because everyone has
shortcomings.
So
this chapter this is the 210th chapter
from the beginning of the book. However,
this is part of the book of
as the book of virtues. The book of
virtues. The virtues of various acts.
Right? the virtues of salah, the virtues
of zak, the virtues of fasting, the
virtues of the virtues of the virtues of
jum.
And so this is one of the 19 books that
is compiled of. We'll read the
chapter title because it summarizes most
of the conclusions to be drawn from the
narrations. And then next week inshallah
as per usual we will go through the
narrations on JA and continue to
go through the narrations during the
occasion of Juma. you know,
henceforth
the chapter title that he gives us here
in Noahi, he is very similar in his
methodology in hadith compilation as the
earlier scholars of hadith. The earlier
scholars of hadith did not to speak
very much from themselves.
They wish to allow the text to say as
much on its own as possible. So when you
look at something Sah Bkari Alm
Bkari, he wrote the chapter titles.
What are the chapter titles? The chapter
titles are essentially
the conclusion to be drawn from the
narrations in the chapter. He's giving
you the conclusion and then saying here
is the evidence for those conclusions.
Muslim
im Muslim did not write the chapter
titles in his book. But you'd be
hardressed to find Muslim in the way
that Muslim wrote it today.
Every print that you could probably find
today of Sah Muslim has chapter titles.
Who wrote those chapter titles? Where
did they come from? Does anyone know?
Fun fact, it's a Neoi
and Nei has a very
very famous explanation
on Muslim called
this explanation of Muslim. One of the
things he did was he placed chapter
titles for the narrations
and he put book titles as well. And he
categorized the book into chapters.
And so the chapters you find in Sah
Muslim are not the words of Imam Muslim.
They're the words of Ani. So after he
wrote most publications
of Sah Muslim when they printed Muslim
they print it with imi's
chapter titles that's what it retains
and so the same way that he did there he
does here which is he places the
conclusion
in the chapter title and then he
bolsters that conclusion with evidences
in the chapter.
He says
the virtues. This is a chapter regarding
the virtues and merits of the day of
and the obligation
of
and the obligation of bathing
on the day of Jum
and putting on some perfume or
this is for men specifically and most of
these rulings are particular to men. Not
everyone is obligated to go to Juma. Not
even all men are obligated to go to Juma
to attend Juma. It's very specific
conditions that make Jum obligatory.
However,
bathing for the day of J and putting
on perfume or
something that smells nice
and the virtues of going as early as
possible to
the
and the virtues and merits of making dua
specific specifically on the day of Jum
which there is a time in which dua is
accepted from every Muslim who makes it
on the day of J which we will get into
inshallah
and the virtues of making a salah upon
the prophet Sam
on the day of J
And this chapter will also
show
and prove what time of the day of J in
which that golden hour is in which dua
is accepted because the scholars differ
on that. What time is it? The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam left it
ambiguous for a reason so that we would
make dua throughout the entirety of the
day but it doesn't mean no one knows
when it is. He's told us when it is. He
says
and this chapter is also regarding the
virtues of remembering Allah much during
the day of J specifically
after.
So notice here that in this chapter he's
given us many of the pro most prominent
rights of the day of jum bathing
attending jum putting on some kind of
or perfume that a person makes dua
specifically on the day of jum making
plentiful salah upon the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam on the day of
jum
that there is a time during the day of
Ju. If a person makes dua during that
time, Allah has has confirmed
and guaranteed that he will accept your
dua at that time because all other times
a person makes dua, it is hopeful to be
accepted. But during these particular
times, it is definite that it will be
accepted as long as the conditions of
dua are fulfilled. And the virtues of
remembering Allah generally and on the
day of J specifically and most
specifically after
J.
[Silence]
Every
Looks like
when the battery goes